um
the last 10 days of my scooter odyssey
have arrived but dark clouds are
gathering on the horizon
i hope that's not a bad omen for the
rest of the trip
the head wind i'm facing certainly makes
every kilometer a real challenge
on my tour of germany i've arrived in
the state of baden-wurttemberg after 71
days in
2144 kilometers i reached schumberg
i started out two and a half months ago
at germany's northern tip
now i have nine days at the most to
reach my destination
schoenberg supposedly is a village of
beards what is that
i asked the residents why it's called
the village of beards i get the general
idea
because there's a beard club and it's
successful because they're world beard
champions and have special long twisted
beards much better than my five o'clock
shadow okay
i think i'd better take a look
so i make my way to the supposedly
amazing beard and mustache club which
claims to be the world's most successful
no wonder with current world title
holders in five different categories
this is how they look
and this is club chairman marcus bross
what's the attraction of wearing a beard
the attraction is that you like it
yourself people around you like it
and that you stand out in the crowd
women like them and why not
those are good arguments
how do you become world champion
easy you present yourself as a candidate
there are 17 different categories you
get assigned to a category and then you
have to stand on a catwalk and there are
seven judges and they say who has the
best beard
is there a fan culture in this beard
scene groupies and stuff like that
yes of course
mainly women over 50 and our wives and
girlfriends they like beards
in the light of this great enthusiasm
for beards these are my top three
third place is ghetto geiger with this
magnificent specimen in the chinese
category twice european champion
second place reinhardt burka with his
musketeer mustache
he's a world olympic and even super
beard
but the winner is france pill with these
stupendous whiskers
three times world champion seven times
european champion and six times german
champion
it's amazing how many different things
there are clubs for in germany there are
more than six hundred thousand clubs
statistically every german belongs to at
least one all you need in germany to
found a club is seven like-minded people
the things that exist in germany are
incredible but now i'd like to find out
how successful i will be with different
beards among the ladies
with the full gray beard i get an
immediate rejection
i don't want an artificial rose
with these glorious curls i
automatically hand over the rose more
self-confidently and it works this lady
agrees to drink a cup of coffee with me
a comment
with this mustache everything goes wrong
beards do seem to be advantageous in
real life 33 more dating success isn't a
bad result
with nothing more than my own
non-designer stubble i scoot further
south towards the black forest don't
worry i'm not giving up